I have suffered with anxiety and
depression mostly depression throughout
my 20s it's rough man like being ashamed
about the fact that you feel sad and you
have nothing to feel sad about was the
worst part of it my depression would
manifest by being in bed bound for you
know a few days at a time maybe once
every few months because I was the owner
director of my own company no one could
tell me where I needed to be I could
make excuses I could get other people to
go and do stuff for me I would just
spend this time lying bed eat food not
open the curtains not want to do
anything hate myself real real low mood
and it would happen consistently sleep
pattern was a massive massive
contributor to that and fixing the sleep
pattern fixed an awful lot of everything
that happened Downstream I always
thought I was depressed for a good chunk
of it turned out I was heavily heavily
sleep deprived and then a bunch of other
things too I'm very very glad that I'm
in a place now where there's still that
that person's still in me but the voice
and the tenor of them are much more
quiet